no this is not an arthouse transporter
[Music]
if I Drive for you you give me a time in
a place I give you a five-minute window
anything happens in that five minutes
and I'm yours no matter what I don't sit
in while you're running it down I'll
carry a gun I Drive so drive stars Ryan
Gosling Carey Mulligan Albert Brooks
Bryan Cranston and Ron Perlman it's by
the same director is Bronson which was a
pretty good movie but with an excellent
performance by Tom Hardy and that's the
met hints of greatness in the director
and I knew that something was coming
here's Drive a movie about a stuntman
Ryan Gosling who does stunt driving for
movies but moonlights as a getaway
driver for criminals he meets a really
nice woman and her son who live in the
apartment building and they strikes up a
really sweet relationship with them but
what her husband who was in prison comes
back some really messed-up stuff happens
I'm not going to divulge but the wife
and the child are now in danger and Ryan
Gosling doesn't like that so he decides
to find the people who are endangering
them and work things out I'll put it
that way so you just moved by I know
I've been here for a while what do you
do I Drive for movies
dangerous it's only part-time I've heard
rave reviews about driver heard great
things about it it was shown at
comic-con the pretty shirt won Best
Director at the con Film Festival drive
is a masterpiece
I don't want to overhype it but this is
the kind of movie that in my opinion I'm
pretty sure that years from now film
classes will be telling the students to
look at people who are interested in
becoming directors or cinematographers
if they're gonna be like look watch
Drive come back we'll talk about this
this is a beautiful looking movie one of
the best directed films of the year so
far I've seen it looks so fantastic each
scene is so well edited and pasted you
would think that some of these scenes
with it where the main people are quiet
and they don't talk that much would be
boring but for me it was riveting I'm
telling you my eyes were glued to this
screen during this movie I adored this
film my husband's coming home what is he
he's in prison there's some guys the
woman to do a job for and I'm not
it is that you got there
one of those men gave you this ryan
gosling plays kind of the man with no
name type he doesn't talk much you don't
know much about him but you're
interested you want to know you're like
tell me more about this guy telling more
and as you see certain things as
characters do sir his actions you can
kind of start to get an idea of what its
past is like the fruits through his
actions you get an idea the kind of
person he is things to happen to him in
his past all the actors are great in
this movie everyone does well with each
other Brooks Carrey Mulligan
Gosling everyone worked really well with
one another the soundtrack for this film
is very retro very 80s did you have any
idea there'd be a second car action
scenes in this film are quick horrific
sometimes actually a little bit
terrifying and very well done and
extremely effective everything about
this movie is 100% not cliched
everything you think it would do it does
it a different way the only thing that's
cliched is the plot I mean we've seen it
before but it's style over substance and
it's not a bad thing for this movie it's
just such an entertaining experience I
don't want to over hide but I keep
saying that but when I watch that movie
I was thinking I wonder if this is like
what people felt like when they first
saw like Pulp Fiction in theaters I mean
the the reaction this type of I don't
know if I'd like that oh I don't know if
I like that oh my god
[Music]
now some people might look at the events
that have it later on in the film and
think boy that's a little over the top
but if you watch very carefully you can
see a lot of times earlier in the movie
where they hint at what's going on in
this character's mind what could happen
and what he might do and these kind of
things and it's very well done
very well directed phone I personally
named the phone as a masterpiece the
night life the look of the film on my
word that look at night just so
brilliant that the action scenes
everything was so perfectly edited I
adored this movie I just sat there
dislike I can't believe this is
happening I mean just certain things in
the movie just really strike you it's so
great it's one of my favorite movies of
the year I'm gonna give driving a
[Music]
so if you liked this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck
[Music]